storms also caused problems for air
travel bad weather left more than 800
flights canceled yesterday in the
busiest day for Thanksgiving travel so
far today at least 180 flights are
canceled and more than 400 have been
delayed Kris Van Cleave is at New
Jersey's Newark Liberty International
Airport where at least 20 flights are
canceled this morning Chris good morning
so what can travelers expect good
morning Tony I think they're going to
expect delays delays and more delays
yesterday more than 8,200 flights left
late take a look behind me here you can
see all the people trying to get through
security here at Newark and get out of
town before this storm ramps up American
Airlines expects today to actually be
its second busiest day of the
Thanksgiving holiday season behind
yesterday and it all really hangs on
this forecast airports a particular
concern our Boston and Hartford's
Bradley but we know there are going to
be delays at all three of New York's
major airports Newark saw some delays
stretching past four hours yesterday for
hours travel waivers are in effect for
Flyers to make changes without a fee to
avoid this weather this delta flight
here slid off the payment pavement
Sunday in Buffalo and some airlines
actually to stop operations for a time
in Ithaca because of the storm yesterday
and it wasn't just in the Northeast in
San Francisco heavy winds and rain
soaked the Bay Area contributing to
ground delays of more than four hours at
SFO now the airlines really see this
with this storm as being more of a delay
driver not something that's going to
lead to widespread cancellations and
significant airport closures of course
that depends a bit on the forecast but
basically they are saying be prepared
for flights to leave late and that is
not good news for flyers who have
connections Tony all right Chris thank
you very much